okay remember cycling range is much it's
much closer it's not out here
okay so he goes
i don't want to move towards his cross
lateral side
i don't want to step here
because he has the other hand so i gotta
move and he starts in jail right
he says he sees me do it
so i'm out here
and i leave that foot for a shiro tank
on he goes
here leave that foot don't step into his
cross lateral weapons
leave that foot come down in the arm
start high and go low so
reach out
not like this this is dreaming
here
then don't walk you're not blocking
you're making contact and yielding
so contact on the inside and heel
okay okay so
on the first move is i reach out
look at his he does his actions he goes
boom where is the end move
right here you see so that's where my
yawn sits
it's the same thing on show me
where it's not down here
it's when it goes up
so the same thing here his hand goes up
and i feel it
what do i fill it with the outside of my
forearm
so that i get the spiral when i come
back
the turning of my forearm
so he's here out he goes
my hand turns
[Music]
fill out
not here outside four
turn with his hand turning
outside forearm turn with his hands
turning
okay let's go there's no uh
movement of my arms laterally across my
frame
i have inward spirals and i have outward
spirals that's all i have
so my my hand is going in
and then my body will move but my body
moves and my hands come down
[Music]
don't bring your hands
my body turns and then that pattern is
done with my body
my hands just come more down down
straight shaft
straight down
find his elbow slide down to his wrist
find his elbow down to his wrist don't
go right for the wrist won't find the
elbow
down to the wrist
find his elbow right there then down to
the wrist
[Music]
um he's not pirouetting for me
okay so he's throwing his strike and
then
i go here and then he turns himself
around he's not
he's not doing that
[Music]
and i'm not doing that to him with my
arms moving laterally
there's energy going this way on his
strike there's energy going this way
and what i'm going to do is as his body
starts to turn
just slightly into it go back because
that's what i want so
his leg comes up right okay when he gets
here
there's energy is now spilling on the
outside of that leg it's going this way
okay and all i'm going to do is make
this leg
take a little hop that way
go and that's what does it to him
it's the same uh kazushi powder we might
have here
forward it's the same one i have here so
i'm going this way
making energy go outside that foot and
the leg will
come around not him pirate so i'm gonna
go here
there's that that's the energy i want
and i gotta make him take that little
hop
and keep it all moving
then it starts spinning outside that
foot
here
[Music]
is not him doing it
and it's not me doing
[Music]
the the pattern is
done energetically so
you will see that i go here whoa
and then i shuffle to get that last
little
stutter step out of here that starts
that position
don't leave your foot down or you're
just here
you'll have to hit that other foot to
come inside
so that the line of gravity falls
outside
let's go okay so he's got the round kick
wow
i'm gonna do the same energy thing
same time
so i don't want to go here because
you'll nail me with the other hand
so i have to do a sheet of tank on
inside
okay
fade and let that new line go outside
in space
don't worry about any take down this
fake
yield and position
okay so if he's doing dopamine
i get that gap like that you're going to
clash with it
okay so aikido already has contact i
mean it goes
contact and then i can never clash with
it
as long as i can yield these the same
thing here
i'm not going oh man or
here catching this thing that's gonna
kill
it's just it's a blend on my body
just like athletes catch balls absorb it
with the body
we're athletes catchy kick
[Music]
so just like this hand i start at the
knee and i come down to the ankle
increase your odds of getting the trap
so pull me ankle
just like the hand elbow wrist
hair pull
so we'll do a goofy throw boom
this is i don't know how's it going
liverpool
thank you to be falling
for me to throw him if it's going to
work okay
so just because i have his leg that
doesn't mean
if he can't do things he can okay so
i have to keep attacking his balance so
we're going
balance that's what i want
and i feed that just a little bit
so it's not like i'm here catch and then
i'm going like that
not gonna fall his line of gravity is
not outside his base support
and i pushed him and he just moves his
base support back under his line of
gravity
so i'm here and then pop
he's going that way it's no different
back to yoko or her
boom he's going that way same exactly
just the fade is here go up
there okay let's go